[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number seven
why do dogs pee on stuff if you have
ever taken a dog out for a walk you
probably notice that when they are
urinating they're not just relieving
themselves they've got some special
project going on they're very careful
about where they go and they don't go
all at once they go in little bits all
over the place
you've probably heard that what they're
doing is they are marking their
territory and that's sort of true but
there's actually a lot more to what's
going on dogs use molecules in their
urine as symbols to communicate just
like we use words as symbols to
communicate when a dog is sniffing a
fire hydrant that's the equivalent of
you checking your Twitter feed believe
it or not there is a group of scientists
called signalling theorists that are
really interested in what dogs are doing
when they're urinating it turns out that
anything can be used as a symbol in a
communication system plants use colors
that they display in their flowers to
communicate to bees hey I've got pollen
I've got nectar come pollinate me birds
will use songs which is fairly similar
to us using words but they will also
flash feathers to communicate things to
each other and even bacteria communicate
with one another they use molecules they
excrete molecules from their bodies to
coordinate behaviors with their fellow
bacteria no matter how weird a
communication system might be as soon as
scientists find out that one exists
they'd like to study it they'd like to
try to crack the code of that
communication system they want to know
what all of the symbols mean in 1971
there was a really interesting study
done on the golden jackal attempting to
figure out what it is that they're
communicating with each other through
urine jackals are a semi monogamous
species when they're raising pups the
male and the female will do so
cooperatively they do it together and
they'll stay with each other and they'll
be faithful to each other while those
children are being raised if it was a
big success they'll actually stay with
each other from multiple litters and
some
even their entire lives if they're not
so successful then they'll find other
mates but jackals are very picky about
who they choose for a mate because once
they choose a mate they're kind of stuck
with them for a while you know they're
gonna put a lot of energy a lot of
effort into raising those pups so you
better better choose a good healthy
strong mate that's gonna help you
provide for those children researchers
found that in order to choose a mate
jackals do what I think is probably the
most hilarious mating ritual I have ever
discovered what happens is that when the
female is ready to mate when she is
mature and she's going into heat she
will go around and start marking areas
all over the place she'll just start
urinating everywhere and there was a
molecule in her urine that the males
understand as a symbol saying that whoa
we have a female in the area and she is
ready to mate I'm gonna go find her and
when the male encounters the female he's
fairly cautious she will urinate in
front of him and then she'll back away
he'll come up he'll investigate he'll
smell it and if he's interested he'll
urinate on top of it and they'll do this
back and forth several times gleaning
all sorts of information about each
other's health and if all goes well if
they like the smell of each other's pee
they will form a bond and they will mate
and they will raise puppies together
now that I think is fascinating enough
in and of itself but it gets better I'm
gonna read to you that I think this is
so funny just the way that it was
written when the female jackal comes
into estrus when she goes into heat the
male with whom she is pair-bonded
follows her and vigorously marks each
spot upon which she has urinated in fact
his behavior is so vigorous that he
sometimes urinate simultaneously with
her the reason that the male is doing
this and they're extremely vigilant
about it I mean every time the female
urinates they're right there to urinate
on top of that to mark on top of her her
spot the reason they're doing is is to
communicate to all the other males in
the area that yeah my lady she might be
in heat but guess what buddies she's
taken a few years back one of my
roommates had a pair of dogs that were
bonded together
and the male would do this with the
female and it was hilarious because he
was so vigorous about it so eager to
mark brushy marks that he would actually
he wouldn't wait for her to finish he'd
actually pee on her leg a lot of times
and she'd get really angry at him it was
really funny to watch but if you think
about this this is the equivalent of you
know when when we fall in love and get
married we you know buy a wedding ring
for our partner it's kind of a way to
mark our territory
it's anyway I thought this was funny the
way that dogs you know profess their
love for one another is by peeing on
each other's pee next question